ta droite qui entend reprendre la main
sur le dossier de l'immigration alors
que le gouvernement prépare un projet de
loi sur le sujet pour l'été les
républicains par la voie de leur
dirigeants passent ce matin à
l'offensive aujourd'hui en vérité ce
sont les juges qui dirigent sur ce sujet
et qui conduisent la politique du pays
le politique ne peut rien la loi ne peut
rien la loi ne sert à rien d'ailleurs
depuis 20 ans on a fait plus de 20 lois
qui ne servent à rien le petit groupe
était escorté vers le rivage par des
hommes masqués pour embarquer à bord
d'un bateau sans aucune idée de sa
destination
pas parce que d'abord j'ai des accords
de fonds notamment sur la réforme
constitutionnelle que propose les trois
présidents qui font la une du Journal du
Dimanche aujourd'hui une série de
mesures parmi lesquelles une
modification de la Constitution qui
permettrait l'organisation d'un
référendum sur le sujet les républicains
qui souhaitent également durcir le droit
du sol puis les passagers sont débarqués
sur un plus grand navire des gardes de
côtes grecques
les voici ensuite mises à l'eau sur un
canot gonflable et laissez à la dérive
notre Constitution ne prévoit pas de
pouvoir organiser de référendum sur ce
type de sujet d'ailleurs Olivier Marleix
le dit également
les référendums tels que c'est prévu
dans la Constitution c'est sur les
services publics c'est sur les traités
internationaux il y a certains sujets
qui peuvent faire l'objet de référendum
ils sont déjà assez larges article 11 de
la Constitution ou même l'article 89
avec une réforme beaucoup plus large et
je crois que la Constitution aujourd'hui
il faut pas y toucher quand monsieur
Giscard d'Estaing proposait la
suppression du droit du sol il a été de
même traité de fascistes de pétainiste
et on lui a dit qu'il mettait de l'huile
sur le feu exactement comme vous chère
madame vous voyez vos grands frères ou
vos grandes soeurs appliquaient les
mêmes méthodes et donc ils cherchent à
déporter le débat oui bien sûr ils
essayent de faire diversion aujourd'hui
le problème du pays excusez-moi de vous
le dire c'est les prix qui ne cesse
d'augmenter et le pouvoir d'achat qui
baisse et des gens qui tirent la langue
ce petit groupe est en réalité poussé
vers les eaux Turcs une pratique
illégale les migrants seront ensuite
secourus par les Turcs aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national ne dit plus rien
parce que vous avez réussi à les une
idée et que ça correspond à la stratégie
de Marine Le Pen de dédiabolisation
seulement à force de te dédiaboliser on
renonce à tout selon le New York Times
la Commission européenne c'est dite
préoccupée par ses images et a promis de
prendre attache avec les autorités
grecques de leur côté elles n'ont pas
répondu aux sollicitations des
journalistes j'essaye d'être juste
pour le consommateur ce que j'ai
moi-même une famille nombreuse j'ai 4
enfants à nourrir et je paye beaucoup de
prix de paquets de pâtes et je sais
parfaitement à quel point c'est pris
sont devenus insupportables pour les
Français ça canne au pied du Carlton
Thierry Frémaux le directeur général du
Festival de Cannes et un policier
municipal Thierry Frémaux reproche au
policiers de l'avoir bousculé et même
frapper dit vous m'avez frappé je vais
porter plainte mais puisque vous me
lancez là dessus on va parler d'un
dialogue entre
Oscar et Julian n'est-ce pas et elle
avait un sourire de Mona Lisa je lui a
tout en gardant les lèvres le plus
souvent à peine écartées comme comme une
petite fente de chair Thierry Frémaux
faisait en fait du vélo électrique sur
le trottoir l'agent municipale lui
aurait demandé de s'arrêter parce que
c'est évidemment interdit de faire du
vélo électrique sur le trottoir une
première fois une seconde fois il ne
s'est jamais arrêté et donc là on a
cette séquence qui a donc été vu 2
millions de fois son regard se troublait
encore plus et elle demandait sur un
temps innocent quand est-ce que tu
manques
764 millions de tonnes le chiffre donne
le tournis ce nombre multiples 0 c'est
celui du poids des bâtiments de New York
un poids gigantesque conséquence la
ville croule sous ses gratte-ciel et
s'enfonce jusqu'à 2 mm par an le prix
n'est pas à sa case
une étude publiée dans une revue
scientifique américaine conséquence de
cette affaissement la ville est de plus
en plus vulnérable aux catastrophes
naturelles et notamment aux inondations
là j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans le
chic du sas un goût de métal mais la
bouche un frisson des froid me parcouru
les Chine où est-ce que vous êtes on va
croire que j'ai eu Manuel Ferrara comme
conseiller
New York n'est pas la seule ville à
s'affaisser en Indonésie Jakarta voit
certains de ses quartiers s'enfoncer
d'environ 11 cm par an